[Music]
on this Monday night ramping up the
response to the koban 19 outbreak we are
in unchartered territory
the steps Canada is taking as the
outbreak grows and the US records new
deaths a draft deal for their wits so it
and people of British Columbia the only
way that we can make Canada better
countries if we do it together what it
could mean for future oil and gas
projects plus the desperate attempts
migrants are again making to try to
reach Europe and we're streaming live
now the new way to get global news on a
device near you
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the outbreak of Co vid 19
and what you need to know about its
spread the numbers keep changing and so
does the advice about travel with March
Break around the corner we know many
Canadians are wondering about their
plans here's where things stand right
now Canadians are being advised to avoid
all non-essential travel to parts of
northern Italy that includes Venice and
Milan that same strict warning is in
place for all of China and all of Iran
plus two cities in the southeast of
South Korea where outbreaks have
occurred Canadians are being told to
exercise a high degree of caution in
other parts of South Korea and in Japan
and starting today anyone who arrives in
Canada from Iran is being asked to self
isolate and monitor themselves for
symptoms the World Health Organization
says there are now nine times more new
cases outside China than inside China
the virus has been detected in more than
60 countries including Senegal Tunisia
Jordan and Iceland though it's important
to note many of those countries have
only one or two cases interrupting the
spread is the goal of public health
experts some infectious disease
specialists say that's no longer
possible because it appears the virus
can be spread by people who have no
symptoms but the World Health
Organization is urging countries to put
containment measures in place
we are still hopeful that containment is
the the right first strategy but clearly
containment with the purpose of slowing
down the virus and if we're lucky and if
we do the job really well we may get the
opportunity we just might get the
opportunity to interrupt transmission
here in Canada there are now 27
confirmed cases after three more
positive tests in Ontario all the
Canadian cases are believed to be linked
to travel there's still no evidence of
community transmission but in the u.s.
that is no longer the case people appear
to be contracting the virus in the
community from people who have not
traveled to countries where there's an
outbreak in Washington State that's just
across the border from BC six people
have now died and authorities are
preparing for that number to rise
because it's believed the virus may have
been circulating there undetected for
weeks
Abigail Beeman has two
top story a germ minimizing elbow bump
greeting as health officials across the
u.s. focus on reducing the spread of the
new corona virus it's spreading to new
states with the first cases in Rhode
Island Florida the first patients an
adult resident in Manatee County without
travel history to China or other
countries identified for restricted
travel by the CDC and New York we are
fully coordinated we are fully mobilized
New York's governor stresses the key is
reducing the spread elimination is
impossible andrew Cuomo promising new
bleach cleaning protocols in schools and
on public transportation and more than a
thousand devoted hospital beds we want
1,000 tests per day test as many as you
can and then isolate those people's
federal officials are promising more
test kits everyone bracing for a further
spike in cases in part because of
increased testing and nationally the
spotlight is really on Washington State
with at least half a dozen deaths and an
increase in cases at this nursing home
the risk for all of us are becoming
infected will be increasing and although
most of the cases will be mild or
moderate the infection can cause serious
illness and there's a potential for many
people to become ill at the same time in
Texas there's frustration with federal
authorities after a woman who traveled
there from Wuhan China was released from
quarantine after testing negative twice
and then brought back into isolation
after a third test came back positive
we simply cannot have a screw-up like
this from our federal partners I know
that my husband's testing this morning
so we're praying for a negative tonight
these women are leaving quarantine in
Nebraska but leaving their husbands
behind for now the men tested positive
after being aboard the diamond Princess
cruise ship which docked in Japan this
pair now has new fears about going home
well my friends shun me when we go back
to her just the community in particular
Malaysia and that's been afraid of us
with the new coronavirus increasingly on
everyone's minds as it continues to
spread
this afternoon US President Donald Trump
and his coronavirus task force met with
pharmaceutical executives the president
saying everyone's goal is to accelerate
the development of a corona virus
vaccine he also said he's eyeing new
travel restrictions but didn't offer any
details Donna okay Abigail Beeman in
Washington thank you public health
officials in Canada say the risk here is
still low and the only confirmed cases
here are travel related that almost
certainly though will change experts in
infectious disease say the window is
closing on what needs to happen to
ensure our health care system can cope
and that includes precautions to keep
frontline health care workers safe and
increased surveillance and testing
instead of waiting for people to show up
at emergency rooms about 2,900 people in
Canada have been tested so far
Robin Gill looks at how Canada's public
health response is being stepped up in
the greater toronto area the Transit
Authority is trying to find passengers
who may have traveled with a 34 year old
woman recently diagnosed with the new
corona virus after arriving from Iran
the fear kovat 19 spreading at the
community level
we're cooperating fully with their
public health authorities to help them
trace the customers on that train and
get get information to them
Canada has a pandemic plan that was
implemented post SARS and tested in 2009
during the h1n1 epidemic it involves a
command center with health experts to
guide hospitals in case of a mass health
scare you always want to have these
things in place before there's the need
and that you're planning for that and
prepared for that Canada's top doctor
says there's a new surveillance system
in place since the appearance of Kovan
19 in this country so these are people
who have certain symptoms like flu-like
symptoms and it's adding the Tobit 19
tests to those kind of testing anyone
showing symptoms is being advised to
call public health authorities before
showing up at hospitals but there's no
way to monitor that and here's why
that's troubling this is a virus that
can be transmitted when people have very
mild symptoms people may not know to
present
and so it is quite possible that those
containment measures will not work in
the long run it's kind of perfectly
prepared difficult to say dr. Soong
Avast Murthy is working with the World
Health Organization to track Cova 19
making sure hospitals are adequately
staffed making sure people know where to
seek care if they need to at the public
level making sure all the supply chains
are readily checked namely masks and
gloves and other personal protective
equipment there's a run on stocks of
cleaning supplies and sanitizers in case
this turns into a worse outbreak for the
most part though
Canadians are remaining calm trying to
not buy into the hysteria that's going
but it could be a matter of time before
the disease isn't just one brought in
through travels not improbable that more
cases will be happening here even at the
community level and health professionals
say that will be the next front in the
battle against this virus Robin Gill
Global News Vancouver other countries
like the UK are preparing for the number
of cases to rise significantly and are
ramping up their preparations there are
39 confirmed cases in the UK now but
public health officials there say
widespread transmission is highly likely
the Prime Minister held an emergency
meeting about kovat 19 today and the
European Union has raised the risk for
moderate to high as crystal commencing
reports everyone is watching what's
happening in Italy Iran and South Korea
it is a mammoth task sanitizing a mall
with the hope of keeping people insole
healthy the number of people infected
with kovat 19 in South Korea has climbed
past 4,000 the highest count outside of
China people are fearful of the disease
and suspicious of those around them this
20 year old student says maybe the
person is my neighbor or passed me by
this is highly contagious so I don't
know what to do I'm worried about going
outside many of the infections are in
the southeast and transmission can be
linked back to members of a secretive
religious sect city officials are asking
prosecutors to file homicide and other
charges against members of the sect
Monday the leader begged for forgiveness
on his knees members did not initially
disclose they had been traveling to
Wuhan China the founder says I'm really
grateful that the government has been
making efforts to stop the corona virus
spread and at the same time I'm asking
for forgiveness in Israel this is what
voting day looks like in the middle of a
global epidemic officials took
precautions so that residents in a
quarantine neighborhood could still cast
a ballot this is a democracy the Korona
a thing is completely under control
today we've taken all the precautions
that are necessary people can go and
vote with complete confidence but there
is no complete confidence a team from
the World Health Organization has landed
in Iran with additional supplies but a
team member on the ground is already
infected with kovat 19 and an advisor to
Iran's supreme leader has died at the
virus Italy meanwhile saw a huge spike
in infections and deaths areas in the
north are the heart of Europe's worst
outbreak of the disease a government
issued quarantine is still in place for
some 50,000 people in 11 towns a student
in northern England who traveled to
Italy is the latest person to be
infected a number of schools have closed
as a result Prime Minister Boris Johnson
says likely the situation here will get
worse but says people should trust in
the health care system Donna okay
crystal commencing in London thanks
breaking new ground in northern BC
coming up a tentative agreement on land
rights and title for the Wits Owenton
though it doesn't mean those rail
blockades are all coming down
construction on the coastal gasoline
pipeline is underway again in northern
British Columbia it's the natural gas
pipeline running through with so itand
territory that's caused so much tension
work was paused over the last few days
while negotiations took place and
yesterday there was a breakthrough a
draft agreement has been reached on land
rights in title for the wood Sultan but
it's a separate matter from the natural
gas pipeline project
Sarah McDonald is at the work site near
Houston BC Sarah Donna work has now
resumed in northern BC on the heels of
that proposed landmark agreement that
could have major implications for this
province and the country with work and
RCMP patrols now resuming on the
indigenous land at the epicenter of
national dialogue on rights entitle the
respect has to has to go right from top
to bottom and throughout the country it
remains to be seen what impact if any
potentially precedent-setting draft
agreements reached between government
officials and one faction of leadership
of what so it's a nation could have on
unrest persisting across the country
because these talks were about much more
than just a solitary polarized pipeline
and more than two decades in the making
it is building on the Supreme Court
decision it is it is about rights in
title a continuation of negotiations
called for in a landmark Supreme Court
ruling only now coming to fruition
doctormick 1997 has been sitting there
for past 23 years or so we are just
picking it up if it is finalized that
agreement could have major implications
for companies looking for access to
indigenous land and resources but it's
not retroactive and it won't directly
impact the lucrative project dividing
this powerful nation the project that's
in place now and the permits have been
in place the it has been permitted it
has been approved and it's under way
this natural gas pipeline fully permit
it and backed by government and band
councils and many what's so it in people
people just want to work our community
wants to work and I think the benefits
are going to be really important to our
people who now hold the power when it
comes to signing on the dotted
the nation's clans will now review the
details of that draft deal in the coming
days and weeks before coming to a
consensus on it the provincial and
federal government said to be ready and
willing to sign it so long as the wood
soda people are Donna all right Sarah
MacDonald near Houston BC thank you that
potential deal in northern BC has not
brought down all the rail blockades in
fact the opposite happened today at
least temporarily a new blockade went up
along a commuter rail line this
afternoon in Montreal our Mike Armstrong
is there Mike what happened well we got
a press release sort of mid-afternoon
saying that there was a blockade at this
overpass behind me and sure enough we
found when we got here about 40
protestors on the overpass as well as
about a dozen police officers police
cars now this was not an indigenous
group this was a group that says it was
inspired by indigenous resistance they
were here about for about three hours
they blocked both freight and commuter
lines now they acknowledge that there
was a tentative deal over the weekend in
BC but they say there's still no
agreement on the coastal gas pipeline
and that's why they were here the
demonstrators left after talking to
police at about five o'clock so they
were here before about three hours now
the gun Oh Auggie rail blockade
continues on the so Shore of Montreal
that's 22 days and Counting there is a
meeting tonight at the longhouse in that
community everyone from the community
has been invited there the question is
whether they take it down or not but to
answer that question they have to decide
whether the progress that was made is
enough or whether they have to have a
resolution before they pull it down
Donna all right Mike Armstrong thanks
still ahead thousands on the move as
migrants move between Turkey and Greece
you are watching global national tens of
thousands of lives are on the line
tonight as Greece and Turkey argue over
a new surge of migrants trying to get to
Europe Greece is refusing to accept any
more asylum applications and a child
drowned when a dinghy filled with 48
migrants capsized off the Greece Greek
island of Lesbos it's the first reported
fatality since Turkey eased restrictions
at its border last week Turkey is now
allowing people to leave saying it can
no longer afford to support the millions
of refugees who have fled there because
of the war in Syria Greece is telling
them to turn back and police are using
tear gas stun grenades and rubber
bullets that land borders to disperse
them all of this is raising fears
thousands more lives could be lost and a
new migrant crisis could emerge in
Europe Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is leading but not winning
after the third general election in less
than a year
voter turnout hit a 20-year high exit
polls show Netanyahu's Likud Party may
again be just shy of a majority that in
Yahoo is the who is the longest-serving
Prime Minister in Israeli history is
facing a stiff challenge from retired
military chief Bennie Ganz and his blue
and white party neither leader was able
to form a government after elections
last April and in September they failed
to make deals with smaller parties to
secure a majority Netanyahu is seeking
re-election under the weight of a
corruption trial it's due to start in
two weeks he has denied any wrongdoing
Jack Welch who led the company General
Electric through two decades of
extraordinary prosperity has died Welch
became one of the most successful
leaders in the US during the 80s and 90s
he was g e--'s chairman and chief
executive and he grew the company from a
maker of appliances and lightbulbs into
an industrial and financial services
powerhouse he was named manager of the
century by Fortune magazine in 1999
after general electrics revenue jumped
nearly fivefold during his tenure he was
also criticized though for slashing GES
workforce earning him the nickname
neutron Jack his wife says he died of
renal failure he was 84
years old next a new approach to
bringing you the news you need
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the way we get our news has changed far
beyond what I could have imagined back
when I got started in this business and
what's writing up stories on a manual
typewriter yep that's how old I am the
options now are just too many to count
we come to expect news and just about
all programming to be available whenever
we need it and want it and as Mike Jarle
reports Canada's first streaming service
for news and entertainment has just been
launched we live in an era of choice
everywhere we look there's a screen
don't like it look somewhere else
technology for all the wonder it offers
has given us a sense of liberating
confusion how many hours a day do you
think you're connected at least at least
12 probably more than a full-time job
sometimes you know I'm up all night like
I barely get some sleep get like four
hours of sleep got to get up go to
school because I'm just it's so
connected and it's always going on and
it's so distracting
it used to be viewers were predictable
they had their favorite couch or chair
and a TV but as the world has become
more connected our devices now are
mostly mobile and that means our TVs are
coming with us as phones tablets and
computers and we expect that content
producers including news organizations
like global will be there to that end
Global has launched an updated version
of the global TV app becoming the first
mainstream Canadian broadcaster in
Canada to offer all its current shows
and live news programming for free while
offering more channel options for cable
subscribers our goal isn't to just be
the number one source of the content
that people watch but to be able to put
it in the kinds of places and kind of
devices that they choose to watch it
it's that accessibility that consumers
are demanding even if their screen of
choice is the smallest one in their home
it's just more relevant that you're
going your phone you come back from
school you come back from work what do
you do you're tired so you just go to
your room
and you don't necessarily always go on a
TV there's no question streaming
services like Netflix are extremely
popular two-thirds of Canadians
subscribe to at least one yet 59% of
Canadians log onto their devices at
least once per day to get their news so
the demand for Canadian content is there
delivery has long been the issue its
evolve or die
it's find alternate sources of revenue
or diet and news organizations certainly
have what they're hoping is that if they
can deliver the the signal for
broadcasters in a new way that will get
people to watch whether it's on a
smartphone or whether it's a whether
it's over the top into you into a
flat-screen monitor or a computer then
they'll be able to get people the bottom
line is Canadians still want content and
are still invested in local and national
news they just no longer want to be
anchored to their homes to get it
microlight Global News Toronto hopefully
they still want an anchor though that is
global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight Sarah Canada is
wolf Island Ferry near the Royal
Military College in Kingston Ontario
thanks for watching wherever you watch
us and hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye bye
[Music]